this seasoned away  [Music]  is an ensemble cast and we're looking  for different Queens who represents the  different genres of drag but beyond that  we're looking for authenticity I thought  you got to see more Vangie on drag race  if bouffant asked me to come to clean  the toilet or be the pit crew or just a  ruffle of her hair I would do whatever  mama would ask me trust and believe miss  van G would do whatever she wanted and  she told me to come out of a box I'll go  back in the box walk backwards I would  do it off  [Music]  to be the first Muslim queen on going to  be on national TV  you know I'm so honored I'm so happy and  blessed  [Music]  oh my god guys you guys are seeing this  she looks like a baby prostitute  realness  [Music]  we produce the heck out of this show but  once you add drag queens to the mix it  always becomes its own monster it  becomes its own animal and we can never  anticipate what's going to happen  [Music]